[Music]
welcome to this afternoon's debate
uh miracle of mind despite the
advances in neuroscience and the rapidly
extending capacity of computers
we still have no adequate theory of
consciousness
no account of how the brain is able to
create experience
and no account of how the material stuff
of the brain
can be responsible for thought should we
conclude that
consciousness cannot be explained in
terms of the physical
and if so what is the alternative or is
it just a matter of time
and one day an ai machine will
miraculously find itself experiencing
the world
and its mere components will have soul
well with me a great panel to explore
this deep and fundamental question
tim crane is a leading philosopher from
what is sometimes referred to as the
analytics school
he's currently professor at the central
european university
formerly at cambridge and has written
widely on the philosophy of mind
susan blackmore is a writer and
psychologist
best known for her book the meme machine
now translated
uh sue i think into 16 languages
something like that yeah
but not so relevant the big textbook on
consciousness is much more relevant
and i was going to say and your textbook
consciousness
and introduction which is surely
something that everyone who is taking
part in this debate should have already
read
and bernardo castro is a dutch computer
scientist and philosopher
and a prominent advocate of metaphysical
idealism a view that's been deeply
unfashionable in philosophical circles
for at least a century
and which he is doing his best to get us
re-engaged in he's also the author of
the book
the idea of the world so
is consciousness purely physical and if
not
what is the alternative so tim if you
can kick off for us
thanks hilary well i think of
consciousness as
um a feature or property of
certain mental mental occurrences mental
episodes
thoughts feelings sensations
conscious sexual experiences
and these are properties ultimately
of living organisms and
they are determined by what's going on
in
inside the organism and what's going on
outside the organism some combination of
those
those things um does that mean that
consciousness
is physical and well here i have to turn
into a philosopher and i say well
i'm sorry but that depends what you mean
by physical the
the idea that consciousness might be
physical has been tied
to the doctrine of physicalism um
which is a kind of inheritor of the
17th century notion of materialism the
idea that everything is matter or
everything is made of matter
um physicalism says something slightly
different because it says that
it it ties its documents to physics
physical science as physics strictly
speaking
and i don't think there's any reason to
think that consciousness
is physical in that sense that it's
physical science is going to tell us
what the nature of consciousness is
and i think consciousness is a feature
that um
of the states of living beings and
not inanimate beings inanimate beings
don't have consciousness
you have to be living to have
consciousness and i
take that to be obvious i know some
people object to the
to this but um you know people are going
to object
so what i want to say is that that's
consciousness is not physical in the
sense that
physicalism or materialism says that
everything is physical
nonetheless consciousness is i think a
property or feature of
organisms which are material objects in
the sense that they have material
properties and
qualities and things like that well that
doesn't tell you anything about how to
explain consciousness or how to
understand it
it's just getting clear on the basic
issue of whether you should think
consciousness is something physical
i think consciousness is something
psychological and the psychological
comes from
emerges out of the biological in a way
that we don't understand
um but that's
my appeal to the idea of emergence there
is is serious
because i think that there are there are
some stages in the evolution of
the world and the evolution of organisms
where um
new things genuinely come into existence
and whether or not we can understand how
those things came into existence is an
open question
thank you uh tim uh
sue well i'm gonna start and probably
end
with perplexity it is so difficult this
this problem um
i want before trying to to answer
directly
just to to say anyone who thinks that
they've got an answer to this i would
suggest is either an absolute genius
or mistaken and
we were laughing earlier about all the
emails that we get with people's
people's theories it is really hard it's
hard because of dualism
um tim has already kind of referred to
that but
sitting here at my desk looking at this
screen
there seem to be two completely kind of
different kind of things in the world
my experience of looking at these poor
faces here or out over there
over the river at the field and the
green trees
all those questions about you know is
your green the same as mine and
how do i know that any of you are
conscious like i am and we can't all
these problems are really serious
now my response to this is
neither of the classic positions
one of which is materialism and um tim's
already said a bit about this
but i would think the vast majority of
people working on consciousness probably
are materialists certainly the majority
um
and they have the problem obviously of
if you believe there is a
material world there and it's
responsible for everything the
kind of things hillary said at the
beginning with which i absolutely
disagree
they've got to try and understand how a
physical brain
can produce consciousness that's the
classic hard problem
defined by dave chalmers as to
understand
how subjective i.e personal private
experience can arise from physical
activity in the brain objective activity
in the brain
it doesn't work if we find ourselves in
the hard problem i think we should
realize we've got something wrong
the hard problem says arises hillary
said is created by
you're stuck in dual in dualism which
nearly everybody agrees doesn't work
but now you take the other view idealism
which i hope we're going to well we are
going to hear much more about
and i i would like to hear how bernardo
deals with this because the classic
problem of idealism is well
why do we think there's a physical world
why does it make sense why do you and i
agree
that we can see these pictures of each
other and you can hear this voice and so
on
i sit of an evening i i love just at the
end of the day just puzzling over there
and it seems to me that in a way
obviously everything's mind
not matter because the only thing that i
have access to
is the experiences the books i've read
that explain about molecules and
and atoms and all that stuff it's still
my experience of reading them
and uh engaging with the science
so i i get that feeling that it has to
all be mined but i
cannot see how then we get physics
and and all of that kind of stuff so
where do i go from there
personally i go to illusionism
i i'm a so-called illusionist
i think the way to tackle this problem
is to say we
we're humans in general with our
language and our upbringing and our
culture and our societies
we are deluded about the nature of
consciousness
we are deluded in the sense that when we
think about consciousness and talk about
it
we say i am conscious of this
there's the the contents of
consciousness
consciousness isn't a container but we
talk about it like that some things come
into consciousness and some go out uh
there's a sort of place where they
happen people look for the neural
correlates of consciousness where it
happens the magic
um you mentioned magic earlier hillary
and that's a problem it's mysterious and
it's magical
so my view is we have to go at this from
two directions
one the scientific and philosophical the
other the personal inquiry
because of course mystics throughout the
ages have said the same thing
we're deluded about the nature of self
and about the nature of the world
and there are many many people myself
included who've trained over decades and
decades to be able to get into a state
where
self another become one uh there isn't
any distinction
due well the problem with dualism has
gone away but i can't go from that to it
to an a a scientific or philosophical
answer
so there we are i'm back to perplexity
and i think that's a good place to be
thank you
i think by virtue of the way we've
defined the physical
consciousness is not physical by
definition and worse yet it cannot even
be reduced to the physical
because of that definition you see we
define the physical
as basically that which has no
phenomenal qualities
that which is exhaustively described
in terms of a list of abstract
quantities such as
mass charge momentum spin geometric
relationships frequency
amplitude and so on and so forth and of
course there is nothing about these
abstract
quantities in terms of which we could
deduce
the quality of seeing a red apple or
tasting the apple
or the quality of feeling a bellyache or
falling in love
so by definition we've turned these two
domains
into incommensurable domains one is a
given
experience the qualities of our inner
life and the other is a
conceptual creation the physical world
i think the way this divide came about
was that um
quantities are very handy for uh
describing the relative differences
of the qualities of experience for
instance
if i see red that's different from scene
blue
and there is a very handy way to
describe this difference in terms of a
frequency delta
which is a number but then we've taken
this description this handy description
of relative differences between
qualities
and we said well this is actually an
existence it exists
in and of itself and we called it matter
and energy or the physical world
out there we gave it an ontological
reality
that it didn't have in the beginning it
was a mere description of something else
and worse yet we not only edified it as
an independent ontological reality
we now try to reduce the qualities which
were
which is where we started to that
conceptual
creation of consciousness which exists
in consciousness
and that of course cannot work i think
the misstep was that um
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas